bonsoir à tous avant de parler de
grandes familles indiennes irlandaise
l'ukrainienne française et c'est vrai
que nous consacrions quelques minutes à
parler d'un grand écrivain qui s'appelle
claude simon et vous le savez tous il
obtenu le prix nobel de littérature 1985
et il y avait 21 ans que les lettres
françaises n'avaient pas été
récompensées par le jury de stockholm
depuis sartre en 1964 qui d'ailleurs
avait refusé la récompense et l'on dit
que jury l'a fait payer ce refus pendant
21 ans donc claude simon qui est à
l'honneur aujourd'hui et puis j'ai
invité son éditeur jérôme lindon à venir
nous parler de claude simon mais il faut
dire aussi et germain dont vous êtes le
le patron des éditions minuit donc il va
publier non seulement claude simon mais
ce qu'on a appelé le nouveau roman
c'est aussi votre triomphe parce que
l'année dernière vous avez obtenu le
prix goncourt avec marie dura cette
année le prix nobel de littérature avait
claude simon pour une petite maison
d'édition jetons que c'est unique au
monde c'est assez extraordinaire quand
même et monsieur vous êtes gêné par ses
confidents je vous comprends très bien
d'ailleurs je réponds parce ce document
c'est une photo qui étaient prises en
quelle année 59 59 alors voilà c'est été
prise devant votre votre devant l'entrée
des éditions de minuit
alors cessons les hauteurs de jérôme
lindon 59 à l'envoyer à gauche alain
robbe grillet qui est le théoricien du
nouveau roman claude simon voyez la csu
qui est chauve là qui est derrière la
haie puis claude mauriac n'est pas un
auteur des menus qui est un ami qui est
un ami c'est ça alors jérôme lindon qui
est là devant l'entrée de sa porte là on
reconnaît robert pinget samuel beckett
alors là aussi voulait que samuel
beckett on ne compte pas parmi les prix
nobel français parce qu'ils et irlandais
mais en fait il est il est édité par
vous et les géants français
alors je pense qu'on pourrait presque en
moins compter la moitié de beckett dans
notre palmarès donc tout cas il est chez
vous et puis nathalie sarraute et puis
claude ollier et il manque michel butor
un tarif est cinq minutes après le après
la photo c'est ça bon des séquences et
de vue photo ex ordinaire quand même qui
vous fait plaisir
oui un bien alors comment claude simon
n'avait pas publié ses premiers romans
chez vous comment est il venu chez vous
il avait publié de ses deux premiers
livre aux éditions du sagittaire puis
cette maison avait eu des difficultés et
il a publié deux livres ensuite chez
calmann lévy et puis ben et par la suite
il m'a fait l'honneur de me proposer de
publier son cinquième livre qui était
qui et élevant à l'epad par les terriens
de robbe-grillet je crois oui par un
scénario de robbe grillet qui oui bien
sûr oublier travailler avec moi pas
hésité un peu un directeur littéraire
grillé oui oui absolument
et voilà bien qu'est-ce qui vous a plu
tout de suite dans claude simonet vu
dinh tien claude simon vous n'avez pas
vu évidemment qu'il ya un jour le prix
nobel mais vous avez vraiment été frappé
par le talent l'originalité de l'oxymore
tout de suite oui bien sûr et quoi ça se
manifester que comment ben écoutez je ne
sais pas moi je sais des choses qu'il
est difficile de dire quand on est en
face d'une page et quelquefois même
d'une seule phrase on a le sentiment que
que c'est très beau et puis on a le
sentiment aussi qu' on va peut-être
pouvoir en tant qu'éditeur servir cette
oeuvre comme elle le mérite ses
sentiments j'ai eu en face d'un livre
comme celui de claude simon qui en plus
à l'époque n'intéressait pas beaucoup
mes confrères en effet ni les critiques
ni les critiques non beaucoup de monde
et mémé en effet dès son premier livre
j'ai tout de suite l'impression de
quelque chose de nouveau à la fois de
nouveau bien sûr mais aussi du parfum de
parc traitement beau c'était le vent
s'est elle élevée en 1957 alors avec un
sous titre quand même temps at-il de
restitution d'un rétablir au quinté même
le titre original puis jo il pensait que
ce serait un peu long et un peu long il
suggéré à claude simon de prendre un
titre un peu plus court et il avait pris
le vent bon alors je vais proposer
maintenant un document qui date d'il ya
douze ans avant apostrophe une émission
que j'ai fait pendant un an et demi qui
s'appelait ouvrez les guillemets mais
une version à les voir à salses dans les
pyrénées orientales
claude simon qui était déjà chaud
bailleurs et plus maintenant à comment
maintenant il l'est beaucoup moins il
l'est beaucoup moins parce que en fait
n'était pas chômé
il se raser la terre israël à peine at
once la race plus qui fait qu'il a l'air
beaucoup d'avoir beaucoup plus de
cheveux il a beaucoup de cheveux bon
alors donc que cette box donc un
document qui date de 1973 et vous allez
donc voir claude simon à l'époque parler
de son travail avec ea games forestière
je ne connais pour ma part d'autres
sentiers de la création que ceux ouverts
pas à pas
c'est à dire mans après mon par le
cheminement même de l'écriture avant que
je me mettais à tracer des lignes sur le
papier il n'ya rien sauf un magma
informe de sensations plus ou moins
confuse de souvenirs plus ou moins
précis accumulés et un vague très vague
projet c'est seulement en écrivant que
quelque chose se produit ce qu'il y a
pour moi de fascinant c'est que ce
quelque chose est toujours infiniment
plus riche que ce que je me proposais de
faire classe sinon pourquoi écrivez-vous
je pense que on écrit d'abord pour faire
parce que tout homme a besoin de de
faire quelque chose
des ponts des maisons des opérations de
chirurgie n'est point besoin de faire
deuxième question fait de deuxième
réponse faire quoi et bien faire un
objet écrit qui se tiennent debout par
lui-même comme il faut qu'une table et
quatre pieds pour se tenir debout qui
soit équilibrée et enfin troisième
réponse
ce qui m'intéresse le plus en écrivant
ses devoirs justement ce qui va se
produire ce qui va se faire par ce
travail voilà alors c'est curieux quand
même expliquer la méthode de drague tout
six mots comme on dit par comme ça mais
en réalité quand même il a eu une idée
maîtresse et même je crois il m'avait
dit une fois que comme ça ils avaient à
propos de la route des flandres qu'il
avait eu il m'a même dit l'endroit
c'était dans un cadre où nous étions
ensemble
l'idée globale de livres il avait
l'impression qu'ils n'avaient plus qu'à
l'écrire la sensation oui mais ils le
voyaient déjà ils n'étaient pas commencé
mais il en avait il y avait l'idée de la
forme générale du livre au fond ensuite
il a travaillé énormément parce que
c'est quelqu'un qui travaille
prodigieusement claude simon mais alors
et c'est libre il y a au fond il raconte
des choses qu'on trouve dans d'autres
romans il parle de la terre il parle des
saisons de la guerre de l'histoire de la
violence etc
mais ce qui est tout à fait original
cesser les montages laisser vivre oui
employer ce mot de montage pas si louis
n'ont pas vous avez raison mais de même
que le ch et claude simon il ya des
papiers collés ou utilisent des des
reproductions d d d d images de toutes
sortes y compris des publicités et avec
cela il fait une oeuvre des oeuvres
magnifiques nouveau qu'on regarde on ne
voit plus au début de quoi se fait et
quand on regarde ça de vrai qu'on on
connaît beaucoup d éléments et puis que
sait faire des choses quelquefois sont
un trivial et c'est une oeuvre
somptueuse
bon alors maintenant je vais vous poser
la question la plus difficile qu'on
puisse poser un éditeur voilà il ya des
téléspectateurs goût téléspectateurs qui
nous regardent qui se dit moi j'ai
jamais lu annick de claude simon c'est
un prix nobel de littérature il ya un
sentiment patriotique qui s'empare des
français en disant absolument que je
livre parce que je veux quand même pas
mourir idiot
alors donc ils vont aborder l'oeuvre de
claude simon fond il faut leur donner
des conseils
par quoi faut-il commencer et par quoi
faut-il poursuivre qu'est-ce que vous
conseillez d'abord mais je pourrais vous
répondre
un peu bêtement qu'il faudrait lire les
livres de claude simon dans l'ordre où
ils ont été écrits par ce que il ya une
progression dans l'oeuvre qui correspond
à quelque chose de très naturel suite le
ciment enfin pour ne pas vous donner les
absolument complète de chinglish de
claude simon je dirais que c'est un
choix un peu personnel que je fais là je
pense à l'herbe qui est un qui est un
livre un peu plus court que les autres
et qui est un livre à mon avis très
simple qui est une bonne introduction en
même temps que que la route des flandres
dans la loire lyon tout à l'heure qui a
obtenu le prix
j'ai eu un bris rivalis hirèche non le
prix de presse à vil prix l'express
essaoui crs défend et qui est un ouvrage
qu'ai-je le livre le plus connu de
claude simon et marie existe en
collection de poche maintenant qu'elle
est traduit dans le plus grand nombre de
langues
oui jusqu'à ce que les héritiers inter
disque
après il ya possible et alors ensuite eh
bien il ya eu qu'est-ce que je dirais je
c'est le palace je crois qu'il vient
c'est le palace qui est un ouvrage qui
situe pendant la guerre dans le dans le
cadre est là et la guerre d'espagne qui
est un très très beau livre que je
croque simon a fait que claudie - il a
assisté en effet il était très jeune à
l'époque
et puis il y à histoires alors qui est
qui est un des grands le grand livre le
bal aussi que le prix médicis il celui
là est primé 1006 j'avais un
retentissement il ya un livre que qui
n'est pas peut-être un de ceux qui est
le plus est que mais comme moi
personnellement je gêne énormément et
qui à mes yeux marque une évolution
intéressante très importante dans
l'oeuvre de claude immense et triptyque
qui voilà qui est un enchevêtrement et
de trois thèmes qui donne une oeuvre
très belle aussi et puis alors il faut
bien dire en apothéose à mes yeux en
tout cas le les géorgiques qui sont qui
ont été publiés il ya trois ans et qui
qui sont tunis enfin qui sont une oeuvre
que j'aime beaucoup
alors les géorgiques pour lequel quelle
revanche timothée venu apostrophe avec
pierre boulez avait fait un dialogue sur
la création la modernité et cetera et
d'ailleurs les journaux d'antenne 2 ont
passé les extraits de cette apostrophe
ce qui fait que j'ai pas voulu j'ai
voulu reprendre un document beaucoup
plus anciens il me paraissait plus
original et bien merci jérôme lindon et
bravo encore pour succès de tous vos
auteurs et venons-en maintenant donc à
l'émission proprement dite le thème les
grandes familles